All right. Welcome everybody to another holistic health hour. Let me get to the chat.
Connect the chat. Hopefully that's going to work this time. I know I missed a lot of your chat
questions before. I'm Dr. Kevin Connors. I apologize for my gravely voice and tired eyes.
We were on a couple days vacation and our flight got delayed delayed delayed. So we're going to get
into really late last night. We didn't have to plan on our drive. So I know for that let's jump to our
questions. A lot of you have said questions in other holistic health hour page. There's a spot
on the bottom where you can ask your questions. So make sure you do that and you can chat. They've
been hopefully I'll get the chat. But we have a whole bunch. So we're better going. Hi all. I have had
some blood results come back from a finger prick test as my doctor refused to allow me to have
any tests done. So I'm I'm had my results and they have shown to be slightly low on B12. So I think
this person is saying they're doctor refused to order labs for horses. So she ordered some different
blood spot labs, which you could do. Anybody could order blood spot labs? You do a finger prick
blood spot test so you can get different labs done. We could do it from home without a without a
quated and getting a draw. However, how do I know what the healthy about should be? So we'll be 12.
Do I go along with the NHS sites say say low high normal or I just don't trust what is given to
by the general practitioners. Good question. I actually have a video of this that talks about lab
value normals. So there's in in short, so I recommend get to our site to watch that video. It's on
our blog post. If you look at blood tests on our blog post, probably 12 of that. But there are different
labs will have different normal lab ranges. So there's lab value normal and abnormal lab ranges and
then there's what's called functional lab value ranges for vitamin B12. I think the I think most lab
value ranges is between 35 and probably one 65 or something like that. I know the functional
range is like 65 to 165. You don't you almost never have to worry about elevated B12 levels. If a person
is taking B12, most of the time they will show elevated B12 levels when you do a blood test. You can
just pretty much ignore that. That can be a sign that B12 isn't getting in the cell. But really what
you're concerned about is low B12. So there's a couple reasons why you'll have low B12. So if it's on
the on the lab value is down near the low range, you could pretty much assume that it's functionally low.
And a person would have functionally low B12 for a number of different reasons. They could have
intrinsic factor issues genetically. They don't make enough intrinsic factor intrinsic factors made by
the primal cells in the stomach. And that's what you need to absorb B12. You can have absorption issues
for other reasons, gut issues, gut inflammation. Hypochloridria is a very common maybe the most
common reason for low B12. If you have a decreased stomach acid production, you're going to have a
decrease in intrinsic factor secretion. So you're going to have low B12. There's also genetic factors
if you have defects on your MTR gene and your MTRR gene, you're going to be more prone to having
issues in absorbing B12 too. B12 and maybe it is quite common. And most people don't have an issue
taking B12. The only thing that I would caution you about if you take B12 is to take a
sublingual lossage would be better. It's better to get some absorption in your mouth
if it's an intrinsic factor issue. So if you take a lossage B12 that you suck on and you let it
absorb in your mouth, you're going to get some absorption through your buccosa. And that will kind
of bypass the issue that you may be having with the intrinsic factor and other absorption issues.
So take take it that way. Second caution is most of the B12 on the market is methyl cobalamine.
And if you, you know, I know that's the big hype that you should be taking methyl cobalamine and
methyl tetrahedral folate because if you have MTHFR defects, everybody should be on that.
Probably is that's just not true. You've got to look at the whole picture. If a person has MTHFR
defects or MTR and MTRR defects, still you don't necessarily want to supplement with methyl groups,
either methyl folate or methyl cobalamine. You want to look at the other genetic
pathways here biopterate pathway, your serotonin production pathways. And if you use methyl cobalamine
or methyl folate into high concentration, it can push that pathway and you could end up with excess
serotonin levels and imbalance in serotonin levels could cause age or rage issues and all sorts of
different problems. So I would suggest to be safe a hydroxyl cobalamine or an adenosyl cobalamine.
Stay away from the cyan cobalamine. So hydroxyl cobalamine or adenosyl cobalamine in a lossage
that would be the best way to support that. Always though, when you have an abnormal blood test,
always always always you want to find out why you want to ask why, you know, you don't just
use supplements like a medical doctor who would use medicine without asking that question why?
You know, go back to, okay, if I do have low B12, you know, what else is going on? Did you get an
adequate, you know, complete CDC and metabolic panel and other things too to see if there's other
things going on? There's patterns for hydrochlorohydria that I mentioned as one of the causes of
low B12. I have a video on that too. So go to the blog and search HCl to search that and you'll see
a video that I created a hypo and created several blog posts below HCl, production of your stomach.
So look at that as well to make sure that you're doing proper investigation instead of just putting
a bandaid on something. Find a functional doctor that could help you with that if you need more help too.
Okay, so sometimes the questions, I don't fully understand the question, but let's read through this.
Carpal tunnel, tendonitis, rheumatoid arthritis, osteoarthritis, arthritis,
is there a permanent solution? I've been taking and making herbal tinctures, tea, soak it in
must-bats, magnesium oil using castor oil compresses just started so far have felt better.
So when a person mentions multiple different syndromes, carpal tunnel, tendonitis, rheumatoid arthritis,
osteoarthritis, arthritis, all those are different things that can have different ideologies.
So yeah, they're all inflammatory, so maybe the common disorder is increase inflammation and
you really need to get down the inflammation or better yet find out why you have an increased
systemic inflammation. But if it's mainly arthritis with joint issues, obviously most of these are
joint issues. Carpal tunnel is a joint but is more so attended issue and a muscular issue with
the brachial radialis muscle on your forearm, so carpal tunnel patients have issues with their forearm,
lots of times they have spasms or swelling in the brachial radialis either due to excess use.
Common data is using your muscle day on a computer. You can get carpal tunnel issues or
typing all day. You can get carpal tunnel issues because you're using those extensor muscles of
your forearm. So working those out, stripping those out, working on origin and certain points
on those muscles can be very helpful if you find it. You can go to a physical therapist or a carpar
that does kinesiology, applied kinesiology, they can best help you with carpal tunnel.
Tendeditis depends on what tendon is involved. Tendeditis is inflammation of a tendon.
It's usually due to an injury. So if there's an injury that tendon can be partially pulled away
from the bone and pushing it back on the bone physically, it's again doing physical origin and
search for work can be extremely helpful. Again, find a chiropractor that your path or physical
therapist who does applied kinesiology. Rubotoid arthritis is completely different than osteoarthritis.
So osteoarthritis is a degenerative arthritis. So if I hurt my knee, played football in college
and now I'm 45 years old, I'm starting to have a lot of knee pain at that spot.
It's because of wear and tear. It's because of abdominal biodynamics, biophysics of that joint
because of an old injury. So osteoarthritis is the same thing as degenerative joint disease,
degenerative disc disease in the spine. That is degenerative arthritis. It's not inflammatory
base. It might have inflammatory components, maybe there's inflammation at that injury,
but it's not caused from inflammation. It's caused from degeneration. Rubotoid arthritis,
psoriatic arthritis, those are autoimmune conditions. So if a person does have a diagnosis of
rheumatoid arthritis and they have elevated RA factor, that's a totally different ballgame. So that's
not a degenerative disease. That's not caused from ill use of your hands or something over time.
Just because you've been in a profession where you used your hands and overused your hands,
that will not cause you that there will not be a precursor to an autoimmune type arthritis.
So the arthritis that are autoimmune based, totally different balla wax. You really need to jump on
our product disease at autoimmune course and start learning about how to deal with autoimmune
disease because you have antibodies against those joint capsules. It's destroyed. That joint,
you're going to have three different phases of autoimmune disease. You need to learn about that. There's
a lot of things you need to figure out what the triggers are and such to help calm that down.
So the question was, is there a permanent solution? Well, it really depends on what we're talking about.
Usually with carpal tunnel and tendonitis, yes, there's a permanent solution. You could heal that
with a degenerative arthritis, not so much a permanent solution. It's about management.
It's about increasing the joint fluid and the joint capsules. There's a lot of different
management techniques for a degenerative arthritis. With autoimmune condition with an autoimmune
arthritis, it's not a cure either. There's its management, but it's a totally different form of
management with an autoimmune disease. So on our product disease at autoimmune course, it's exactly
why I created that course so you can understand what an autoimmune disease is, how to deal with it
and how to deal with the triggers that could go along with autoimmune disease. Okay, next question.
This one's a really long one, so I'm not going to even read it all. What do you need help with
mind-debit paid from cervical lumbar spine, degenerated herniated compression discs with
old spurs, akylosis, phytonitis, rheumatoid arthritis arthritis arthritis. This might have been the
same person that asked another question. So there's just a way that I can give more of a detailed answer
for somebody with a very complex multiple different cold morbid issues. So you really need to
apologize, but something, you know, I just this is not really the more map to be able to help somebody
with a complex issue like that. So feel free to go on our website. You could make a start off with
a case review. Maybe that would be the best way to go when we could kind of break some of these things
out and work through some of these things. Question came in on Facebook. What is a good herbal for
dysmetaria? I had culture a week, a paid every month, whether I have menstruation or not.
There are a lot of different herbals and adaptogens that could help balance hormones. However,
I mean, you could just, you know, there are a lot of different products on the market that you could
just trial an area. That's what most people do. However, I know I think it's best to test and find a
line. So getting a Dutch test done would be I think the first thing to do. So if you, you know,
if you were a member of ours, that's what I would push you for to get a Dutch test done to measure it.
I know how down that every week, but, you know, the kid, I understand that testing costs
money and people are hesitant to spend money to find out what's going on. If they're a
sure it says a pay for it. And I understand that struggle. But I also understand that if we just
throw a dart at a dart board, we may hit it, we may dock. There's a lot of different herbals on the
market for balancing hormones. If you're going to go that route, I would start with some adaptogens
to see if you can balance your hormones that way. But the best way to do this is to know what you're
doing. So you only know what you're doing is if you run some lands. So getting a Dutch plus done
or a Dutch complete done. And you can get that through our courses on our website. You can order that
and measure your hormones. So you're measuring your estrogen, your progesterone, your
allergens, and, you know, all the cortisols. So you really get a measurement. It's going to be the
best way to go. I'm sorry, I don't have like a, I'll just take this and it's going to solve it.
And quite honestly, you guys, every leery of somebody that says that, at least that says that a lot.
Now there are some things that, you know, you could, you could say that for. I have a digestive
issues that I know I have decreased HCl. What should I do? Well, you should take HCl, right?
It takes a digestive enzymes. When you talk about we don't really know really what's going on,
it's better to test. I mean, a person could have dysmetaria. And they have hybrids, you know,
so how do you know that? Unless you do some tests and you look at some lab levels,
also good to get a CDC. Make sure you don't have adenia issues going on. That would point to
something like that's more serious, like a fibroid or a, or a varietist or something like that. You
want to make sure that you don't, you want your doctor to be thorough, right? You know, I'll
need to give you answers that are thorough. So that's what I would do is to always measure if you could
possibly do that. Next question, what do you recommend for immune support for kids who are prone to
allergies, ear infections, and sinus infections? So depending on the age of the child,
testing can be done as well. Again, and it sounds like a broken record, but okay,
let's say by two-year-old, this gets ear infections and allergies on a regular basis, and I've
run it with a pediatrician in there. Give me the antibiotics. First of all, 99.9% of ear infections
are not bacterial based. So taking an antibiotic is just doing more harm than good. You're just
damaging the gut and the flora throughout the whole body. You just highly don't recommend that.
Unless you tested, unless you did a blood test and you had elevated white blood cells and elevated
neutrophils and suppressed lymphocytes, then you'd say, okay, this person has an infection and
doing an antibiotic is the right course of care. But if they just looked at the ear and say,
you have an ear infection, here's the antibiotics. That's just, that's just about practice. That's
just wrong. So don't do that. There's reasons why. So I always dig into the reason why, right? So if
a child has irregular ear infections, you start thinking of what your comment was on this question.
Does this child have allergies? Most common thing for regular ear infections, regular sinus infections
are food based, not environmental based. Unless the child, you know, getting getting a good
history is important, right? So, oh, I only get these in the spring when pollen is flying.
Then I get ear infections, I get allergies and sinus infections. Well, it's probably that environmental
based and something like pollen or something. But if no, this happens throughout the winter,
when there's no pollen in the air, then it's probably food based or chemical based. So a sensitivity
to most common, what would it be? Gluten and dairy, most common, right off the bat. So if they have
a gluten or dairy sensitivity that means if they have antibodies to gliated in any of the gliated
peptides, or they have antibodies to KC, you're just going to be, they're eating that stuff.
You're just causing inflammation. KC, especially is going to be very beautiful for me.
And there's the problem most likely. You could also have antibodies to chemicals in the environment.
You know, the most common would be food based, but definitely chemicals in the environment
from fluoride to mercury to a whole bunch of different things could be things that set it off as well.
So, many times a person has antibodies to foods that's causing the issue and then they just get
tipped over by pollen or something like that. So really, pollen is a primary thing. That's just
what tips them over. So they're already so near the threshold of a hyperinflammatory response
and then spilling out, you know, increased mucus formation and then they end up with other symptoms.
So what did you do for that? You have to investigate. You have to find out what is the thing that
is causing the inflammatory response. So putting on your Sherlock Holmes hat if the kids are too
little to do a blood test and just start doing some food elimination diet. So again, most common
food would be dairy and gluten. It could be followed by dyes and additives,
calories, glyphosates, chemicals in the food. That's going to be your most common thing is food
based food sources. So clean up the diet, go organic as much as possible. You know,
kids that have this, even if they cut away down a dairy and gluten, they would have, you know,
decrease in their symptoms. So look at that. Next question. I don't know if it's from the same person
or not. Had an ear infection in a four month old was given. A medication is now having diarrhea and
rash. So again, an ear infection in a little child, you know, such a slim chance that it's bacterial.
For them to give you an antibacterial drug, it's just going to cause gut issues. So
and now they have diarrhea and a rash. So they, you have to make sure that you, if you're breastfeeding
this four month old child, that you're getting good probiotics, you're getting a heavy,
good diet with different, as many different types of food as you possibly can. You know, a variety
diet is super important for your gut health and your flora health. You're not going to just build
your floor by taking a probiotic. It's a variety of foods in your diet is really, really important.
That's going to pass through the breast milk. Hopefully your breastfeeding and that's going to help your
child. I would not give a child an antibiotic unless I knew that they had a bacterial infection.
Not against using antibiotics. It's just responsible use of antibiotics. You've got to use
an antibiotic that you know that you know that you know that you have a bacterial infection.
There can be other environmental things for these things too. One thing is it's mold in the
household. We run a microtox test, which is a urine test that a lot of our members, and it's
amazing how many people come out positive with that. There's mold in their house. There's mold
exposure that you know they've been exposed to at some point in their life. A microtox test is
tested for active mold in the person's body. It's tested for toxins that the mold produces.
So if you have microtoxins, those are poisons that are produced by different molds. So you're
going to get into your food. You're either getting into your moldy building syndrome type thing
or you're exposed to them in your past house that you live in or your past workplace or
church or something like that. You've got to deal with it because these things are poisons in their
bed. Next question. Do you have any additional information about calcium supplementation?
I don't know about additional information you're talking about because I'm not a super big fan of
calcium supplementation unless the person is diagnosed with metastasis to the bone
and or a diagnosed with a decreased calcium bone formation and then even with that you still want
to use MK4, MK7 with the calcium. We have a product at our store that's a call. Look at
the product. It's the only one that I recommend. Osteo K, that's the name of it. It is,
it's got vitamin D, it's got calcium, only 200 milligrams in two calisels. But you think, wow,
that's not very high. That's right. You don't want to ever take high dose calcium. So if you take
high dose calcium, it's going to be deposited in your arteries. And that's going to cause
athlete's growth. So you do not want to ever take high dose calcium. And it's really the the
vitamin K2 as the MK4 form that is going to be the most important to help give calcium into the bones.
Otherwise, it's just going to be deposited in the arteries and you're going to end up with hard
issues. So don't ever let any practitioner convince you that you need to take high dose calcium.
That is just not the right thing to do taking. So I should do a, I don't think I have blog post
about this. I will have to make one. Next question. I have had blood results come back that I know
a lot. How to increase progesterone production in women with normal LH, that's the nice
it hormone, FSH, follicle, stomach, stimulating hormone, and E3G levels currently act a healthy way
and take chestberry and earthly's nourish herda truly and earthly's fertile boost.
Okay, so I don't sell those products. So I would literally have to Google them and see what's in them.
So if you're trying to increase progesterone production,
my question is would be why in the first place, what are you trying to do? Did you measure it?
So if the person answered yes, I measured it. I did a horrible profile in my progesterone is low
and I read I have you know all these symptoms of low progesterone or I'm trying to get pregnant.
That could be an issue. A person can have difficulty getting pregnant because they have low progesterone
or they've lost babies and they're trying to be able to hold a pregnancy. It can be because of low
progesterone. It's fairly easy if you know those things and you're trying to then boost progesterone
levels up. It's fairly easy to do so because there's a lot of topical progesterone on the market.
So I don't know those products that you just mentioned in the question whether they have progesterone
in it. If they're oral products, I mean you're taking a pill or they're a powder or something like
that that probably doesn't have the progesterone. So the progesterone that you could buy on the market
is a serum or a cream and you put it on your belly or your thigh or you absorb that and it works
wonders to boost your progesterone. So that's the easiest thing to raise really from a hormonal
standpoint is progesterone. You can like oh I don't want to take hormones and I don't want to take
any progesterone. You can just stimulate through adaptogens and I would assume that that's what
these products that you mentioned are some adaptogens. So taking those if you haven't started those
or you just started taking them and then measure your progesterone again that would be the thing to do
if it's still low then you could probably go with with the serum topical. Next question my white blood
cell count is very low. I have leukeopenia. How can I increase my white blood cell count?
Help. Again, what if I know why? So why does a person have low white blood cell count?
So if the person has low white blood cell count because they have cancer, they have a diagnosis
of cancer, they've been dealing with cancer and maybe they went through chemotherapy and then they
have chronic low white blood cell count because of that. That is a common thing that we do with here.
You can also have low white blood cell count because of chronic infection. So somebody has like a
chronic Epstein bar especially a chronic viral infection can be can just drain their white blood cell
count. So that could be a cause of white blood cell count. But you do want to find out why. So
and then boosting your white blood cell count is not very easy. So you could do things to help support
white blood cell production medicinal mushrooms can be beneficial. There's, you know,
again, it's so I hate to get too technical here because it depends on what you've got going on.
If you have an autoimmune disease, then you have to be careful of taking a bunch of immune
stimulants. So a person with a chronic autoimmune disease could also have suppressed white blood cell
count. And then if you're going to take immune stimulators like vitamin C and things like that that
are going to be natural stimulators like herbal Acidation, Stregalists and things like that that you
think of if you that you take if you had a infection or a viral infection or a bacterial infection,
it can make you worse. So you do want to discern and get a differential diagnosis whether you
have an autoimmune disease as well. If you know that you have an autoimmune disease that I would stay
with the medicinal mushrooms and the vitamin D, I would get your vitamin D level checked as well.
Many times the low white blood cell count person can have a vitamin D level of about 30. That's
very low in my book. You want to get it, you know, at least twice that much. Getting your vitamin D
elevated can be helpful using medicinal mushrooms can be helpful. And the reason why I say sticky
to those two if you have an autoimmune disease because those are immune regulators. They're not
immune stimulators. So they will help bring up your white blood cell count if it's low
but they won't bring it up excessively if it's already high. Versus immune stimulators like
different herbals like a mentioned Stregalists and Acidation and even Vitamin C and even SIG can
take you something that you would take thinking that you have a bad cold or you're coming down with
something that is an immune stimulator is not a good thing to take if you have an autoimmune disease
because you're going to increase the attack on cell tissue. So it really sometimes hard to answer
these questions because I don't know the background. So we, you know, everybody's a little bit different
and you just not a simple answer. Next question. Hello, how are you doing? Thank you.
I would like to know more about how the pancreatitis cancer is treated. So
pancreatic cancer is treated. I would like to, I would like a lot more about vitamins and how to use
that with other medications. Okay, so pancreatic cancer is just a one form of cancer. How is it treated
from from a oncological standpoint? They're definitely going to use pretty heavy dose chemotherapy
with that. And there's a certain type of surgery that they do with pancreatic cancer if you're
a candidate for that depends on what it looks like on the CT and MRI.
From a natural standpoint, pancreatic cancer is treated differently depending on who you go to.
So if you use, there's lots of different natural approach to cancer. So in our, in my book,
I talk about making sure you get tested for how to treat it. There's lots of different natural
cancer treatments that can be extremely beneficial. But not for everybody. And what are you going
to choose to do? You know, you search cancer treatment, alternative cancer treatment, and you can get
bombarded with information that is that may not apply to you. So we do cheek swab testing in our
office. That makes us quite unique. So we get specific in our protocols. But just to be honest,
it's everybody's different. We help people with pancreatic cancer that are, you know, every single
person is on a completely different protocol. If you go to our stop by your cancer course,
it does give you some ideas of different protocols, things to start with.
What are the common protocols with pancreatic cancer would be using enzyme therapy. So you're using
fairly high dose enzymes, pancreatic enzymes, that you take an empty stomach
to help break down the, the slime layer around a growing cancer so that your immune system
can get at it. But you also have to couple that with the immune stimulation therapy. We use
rife therapy, you know, with, I highly recommend that for everybody. That's doing, that has a
cancer, any kind of cancer diagnosis. The beautiful thing about the rife is that I believe that it
really helps, if you're doing chemotherapy, helps the chemotherapy target the cancer,
matter so you're going to have, I think, better results. I think years down the road, if we're still here,
and the Lord doesn't tarry, that I think the rife will be used by oncologists to help
chemotherapy target cancer. But as far as you said, I'd like to, I'd like a lot more,
like to maybe learn a lot more about vitamins and how to use them with other medications.
So there are some interactions if you're going to go and, you know, using chemotherapy, you don't,
if you're going to use chemotherapy, you don't want to use antioxidant antioxidants as far as
supplements go. So your oncologist would, would state that to you, I hope. So you make sure you tell
your oncologist if you're doing, if you're doing about just supplements that you decided to pick out,
if you're going to do chemotherapy, you don't want to take antioxidants at least for 48 hours
after you do the chemotherapy. This chemotherapy is a oxidative agent.
Next question, is there anything holistically that can be done or used for a schwanoma?
So a schwanoma is a tuber around a nerve. So the nerves in the periphery, not in the brain,
but in the periphery, have myelin sheath cells. And the myelin sheath is made by schwan cells
in the nerves in the periphery. And a schwanoma is a tuber, it could be anywhere,
so it's anywhere on the schwan cells. So what can you do holistically for a schwanoma?
Well, what can you do holistically for a tuber? So again, rife would be my first choice. I would
start using rife therapy to help your body attack that, to break that down. So a schwanoma is a
tuber that's typically not going to be, you know, anything that's going to be deadly or anything,
but it could be very uncomfortable and cause all sorts of issues. So I would use rife
technology, PEMF can be helpful too. Anything that's anti-inflammatory can be helpful, so the
flavonoids can be helpful with that. So those are the things like curcumin, rosemary,
trawl, greek, t-extract, you know, things like that can be very helpful with that.
Schwanomas can be formed post-injury, so when you dig to causes of schwanomas, usually it's like,
something, you know, on your foot that you damaged or something like that, so it can be post-injury,
post-stress typical causes in Schwanoma. So anti-inflammatories, rife technology,
even using electrical frequencies like the tens unit can be helpful for that as well.
Okay, any other questions coming in? Let me check the, so thanks for joining us.
Today's call. Make sure that you go to our holistic health, our site, and you'll see all
our own calls, hopefully somebody asked a question that you were interested in. Also go to our blog post,
I mean, our blog on our site, we have well over a thousand blog posts, and if you just do a search,
we have a very nice search component, and you could find, you know, a lot of things that you
may be looking for, so you don't have to necessarily wait until our next call. So go to holistic health
hour, and by the, all our other holistic health hours, and go to cuttersclidic.com.
Let's see when at ERS, you go in at ERSclidic.com, we'll go to our blog post, search our blogs,
you'll find something interesting. A lot of our videos, I made a lot of videos, I know I talked
about HCL deficiency, I made videos on that, and looking at functional lab values versus
the medical lab values, I made videos on that as well, cuttersclidic.com. Go to our blog. Thanks so much.
Bye bye.